[Música]
28 personas perdieron la vida cuando el
avión en el que viajaban se estrelló
contra una formación rocosa en el lejano
oriente de rusia así lo confirmaron las
autoridades del país según las cuales
los restos del avión fueron hallados a 4
km del poblado de paraná tenemos reporte
desde moscú
o inicia la versión número 74 del
festival de cine de cannes después de
que la edición 2020 fuera cancelada
debido a la pandemia de kobe 19 esta
edición estará marcada por estrictos
protocolos por el virus y en jurado
estará presidido por primera vez por un
director afroamericano spike lee tenemos
reportes desde la riviera hablando
hoy les presentamos el segundo capítulo
de nuestra serie dedicada a aquellos que
se recuperaron del cómic 19 hablamos con
ellos un año después y hoy les
presentamos la historia del profesor
maxwell quien estuvo internado en su
propio hospital y hoy ya recuperado
sigue luchando para salvar vidas
actualizamos la información de américa
latina y del mundo aquí hembras 24 mi
nombre es liliana valencia en rusia las
autoridades confirmaron que no hay
sobrevivientes entre las 28 personas que
viajaban a bordo del avión an-26 que se
accidentó este martes cuando cubría la
ruta de petropávlovsk kamchatski hacia
paraná en la península de kamchatka pero
en el camino se habría estrellado contra
una formación rocosa cuando se preparaba
para aterrizar
previamente hablamos con esto con
responsable moscú xavier con las que nos
entregó los detalles del accidente se
confirma que el antonov desaparecido hoy
en la península de kamchatka en el
extremo oriental de rusia ha caído al
mar y van 28 personas a bordo esta
mañana se ha identificado ya el lugar
donde ha caído el aparato según las
agencias rusas se enviaron de inmediato
buques al lugar y según las últimas
informaciones ya se han encontrado
restos del fuselaje la comunicación con
el aparato se perdió cuando iba a
aterrizar en paraná que es un poblado de
unos 3.000 habitantes situado en el
noroeste de la península de kamchatka
según la agencia detrás
aéreo rosaviatsia las condiciones
meteorológicas en el momento del
aterrizaje eran complicadas y las nubes
tapan las montañas cerca del aeródromo
el antonov 26 había salido de la ciudad
de petropávlovsk kamchatski con seis
miembros de la tripulación y 22
pasajeros a bordo en la operación de
búsqueda y rescate participan dos
helicópteros un avión del ministerio de
emergencias y grupos de rescatistas a
estas horas parece claro que no hay
supervivientes
cambiamos de información porque este
lunes la corte suprema de justicia de
honduras declaró culpable a david
castillo como coautor del asesinato en
2016 de la ambientalista berta cáceres
en el momento de los hechos castillo
ocupaba la presidencia de la empresa de
esa constructora que desarrollaba el
proyecto hidroeléctrico al cual la
ambientalista se oponía junto con el
pueblo indígena lenca y por me rosa
pérez mateo
[Música]
victoria y memoria para la líder
ambientalista berta cáceres este lunes
la corte suprema de honduras condenó el
ex presidente de la constructora de esa
que edificaba la presa hidroeléctrica
agua zarca en territorio del pueblo
lenca proyecto al que cáceres y su
comunidad se oponían el fallo fue
contundente en declarar culpable a
roberto de dicastillo por el delito de
asesinato ejecutado con alevosía
atribuyéndole en la condición de coautor
o coautor del asesinato la sentencia
concluye que cáceres fue asesinada por
liderar el movimiento de oposición a la
presa además el tribunal accedió a las
comunicaciones entre david castillo los
sicarios y otros directivos de la
empresa en que definían el crimen
estamos contentas y seguimos en
resistencia porque también tenemos la
certeza de que con david castillo no
termina esta lucha los compañeros de
lucha de cáceres quieren escalar en la
búsqueda de responsabilidades
la puerta a la autoría intelectual pero
que también hoy se le rinde homenaje a
la memoria de las tres una después
luchadora de este país que justamente
luchó contra él y judía por los derechos
de la población el asesinato de berta
cáceres conmocionó a su pueblo y al
mundo entero había sido galardonada en
2015 con el premio goldman la máxima
distinción a los defensores del medio
ambiente 7 personas ya están condenadas
por la autoría material del crimen la
pena impuesta a david castillo como
autor intelectual se conocerá el próximo
3 de agosto
pasamos a la información de cultura
hembras 24 y hablamos del festival de
cine de cannes que empieza esta noche en
la ciudad gala para su versión número 74
este gran encuentro del séptimo arte
regresa después de que la edición 2020
fuera cancelada a causa de la pandemia
de kobe 19 este año el jurado estará
presidido por primera vez por un
director afroamericano se trata de spike
lee ampliamos esta información con
nuestra enviada especial erika olavarría
el que cuéntenos cuál es el ambiente que
se vive en can con el regreso del
festival tras un año muy difícil para el
mundo del cine debido a la pandemia de
kobe 19 y qué restricciones permanecen
también y además que se espera para esta
noche en la apertura
liliana un muy buen ambiente recordemos
que este festival se aplazó normalmente
el festival de cannes tiene lugar en
mayo pero este año a raíz de la pandemia
tiene lugar en julio y además de hacer
mucho calor aquí en la clase hay un
ambiente muy especial ya que obviamente
no hay mucha gente especializada hay
muchos periodistas pero no los 40.000
que cada día vienen tradicionalmente al
festival porque hay muchas restricciones
todavía de viaje entre los países sin
embargo están los veraneantes y
recordemos que cannes es un destino muy
importante de vacaciones de los
franceses que también producto de la
pandemia están pasando más sus
vacaciones en francia que en el
extranjero restricciones para la prensa
básicamente hay que tener un pasaporte
europeo sanitario eso significa tener
las dos vacunas al día para poder entrar
a ver a las películas sino hay que
hacerse un test salida hay todo un
laboratorio a los pies de el palacio de
festivales que ustedes ven a mis
espaldas con esa alfombra roja y no
habrá el beso francés tradicional del
delegado del festival a los artistas
cuando terminan ese paso por la alfombra
roja esta noche comienza ya la
competencia oficial son 24 películas que
van
juzgadas por este jurado que tú decías
el presidido por spike lee esta noche
tenemos el estreno de annette del
francés leos carax o un director raro
protagonizada por marion cotillard y el
actor de moda en hollywood
adam driver el director tiene más de 60
años y es su primer proyecto en inglés y
gracias por la información desde kant y
más adelante en otros capítulos en estos
las emisiones de france 24 más del
festival de cine francés en segundo
capítulo de nuestra serie dedicada a
aquellos que se recuperaron del coi 19
regresamos al hospital de the move donde
encontramos a profesor maxwell hace un
año padeció la enfermedad y estuvo
internado en su propio hospital y ya
recuperado sigue en primera línea en la
lucha contra el virus
un reportaje de nuestros periodistas en
la ciudad
sí
el profesor sobre el se volvió de nuevo
el jefe de servicio dinámico que era
antes de la enfermedad
nos habíamos reunido hace más de un año
en su unidad de tratamiento del dolor
transformada entonces en una unidad como
estaba hospitalizado en su propio
servicio sus pensaba la cantidad de
muertos que había la velocidad
porque ahora salvamos a la gente y no
solamente le sube hay patologías que
aparecerán otro
después de su entrevista fui transferido
a la unidad de reanimación de cuidados
intensivos en el hospital henri mondor
debido a mi degradación respiratoria de
el trabajo de las unidades médicas como
la del profesor sobre él era menos
mediatizado que el de los servicios de
reanimación o trabajo sin embargo
primordial en el marco de la atención a
los pacientes hobbits y el trabajo de
los equipos médicos era apreciar bien a
los pacientes bien apreciados por su
evolución
eran una reacción muy rápida y muy
eficaz que permita hacer pasar las
etapas sin irse a reanimación
la dedicación total de los médicos
durante la pandemia tuvo consecuencias y
desafortunadamente hubo mucha licencia
por enfermedad
diría que la crisis del cobi precipitó
su partida
para mí y mis colegas que se quedaron
era una experiencia humana
estábamos en una situación que nos
recordó nuestro papel principal de
médicos y pando en metz 11 de tratar de
salvar vidas
con el flujo de la pandemia el servicio
retomó su actividad de tratamiento del
dolor con pacientes un poco abandonados
durante las olas sucesivas de kobe
y finalizamos con información deportiva
porque la copa américa ya conoce su
primer finalista se trata de brasil que
venció 1 por 0 a perú en la noche de
ayer hoy se conocerá el segundo
clasificado que saldrá del encuentro
entre argentina y colombia también habrá
acción en la eurocopa con un partido
entre españa e italia quien gane este
encuentro se meterá en la final del
torneo europeo
así finalizamos en 224 ustedes pueden
continuar con más en francés 24 puntos
nos vemos más adelante con más
información
[Música]